I see a TV show called Maggie oh in your
future actually we both know you already
watched all of the episodes that's right
I actually act in that show yeah you're
in it I'm Nicole Sakura I'm Rebecca and
we're in Maggie on Hulu that's right
which is streaming right now so go I'm
still holding your hands yeah they're
actually getting kind of clammy
[Music]
thank you
let's begin
you will fall in love it's gonna be
unlike anything you've ever experienced
you okay
see my own future it's never happened
before this is gonna be good
I went with a kid no way
oh you're on the princess not exactly
lady-like Behavior
I've been waiting for this day
solar opposites are back for season
three oh that rules
oh boy here we go
and we are finally able to do this sweet
ass Tick Tock dance
90 of my fans listen to me because of
the pain they relate to in my lyrics
the media chose to light me off
[Music]
but I never gave up
just don't think anyone saw me coming
after she gave birth shamani was
complaining that she had really sharp
chest pains black women are four times
more likely to die than their white
counterparts with the same symptoms we
fight against maternal morbidity if
these numbers were flips around and
when we're dying through
crazy
oh my God Louise don't go down there
it's dangerous
oh what's this thing I don't know
fresh hot Burger sexy Burgers Lynn it's
Sama and sex sounds baby
do you even want to be a politician
I mean do you
are you running against Brent I have an
idea I think at this point
[Music]
are you even into guns it all started
when I met a woman
Alexander Pierce wanted in 14 countries
there are two men trying to break down
the door
think you are him I am sorry
people say violence is not a way to
resolve problems but I have a plan
my motive
I want to change the world
lately I'm not where I thought I'd be
this is my mess to fix I don't want
anyone under the impression that you did
all of this for me because you're my
boyfriend
ex-boyfriend College made me who I am
and I just know it can be all of that
for you you're right I mean this is
college who cares
I just listened to your podcast
[Music]
like I'm broke too
but there's no condom for your heart you
ready
Miley Cyrus had a song titled party in
the black party in the nude
my strategy is to be the realest liar
that I can be people are being
disrespectful whoever can keep their
celebrity relative a secret will win one
hundred thousand dollars
on hey Rachel I'm sorry Gavin
oh no
exciting stuff
great white Stakeout here we go
what could go wrong
oh my gosh
[Music]
[Music]